these protesters say they're being
punished for wanting an education
their demand is simple a woman's right
to go to university
but they say open Defiance of the
Taliban government is increasingly
putting them at risk
it Taliban turned out demonstrations
into violence the girls were beaten and
whooped we ran away some girls were
arrested I don't know what will happen
on Tuesday the Taliban banned women from
higher education blocked from entering
campus students are coming to terms with
a very different future than the one
they imagined
this training center was our hope what
can we girls do we were full of Hope and
came here to learn it is really a Pity
the Taliban have taken all our hopes
the Taliban came today they beat us and
kicked us out of the training center and
said that you no longer have the right
to study we are in a very bad situation
the girls here they've lost their Spirit
the government says women's faculties
weren't following their interpretation
of Islamic law
it said the policy was an internal
matter and warned foreign powers not to
interfere but the move has been widely
condemned
U.N Global education Envoy Gordon Brown
said the world can't stay silent in the
face of discrimination turkey is foreign
minister said the ban was unislamic and
inhumane
the Taliban has imposed growing
restrictions on women's freedoms since
they returned to power in 2021
but despite the risk of reprisals some
are still pushing back warning that the
potential of a generation could be lost
Fenton Monaghan Al Jazeera